but I do think one of the the the weaker
elements of of Anarchy and
libertarianism is when it comes to
specifically children I do believe
children deserve to be protected uh I do
believe that there should be elements
and institutions in charge that protect
children from uh what's what's online
from other Predators from other people
taking advantage of them from other
people trying to hurt them
psychologically physically and mentally
who is the the was it Austin Peters
Peter he was on the debate stage when
someone said legalize heroin for
children and he said no and he's known
as the guy saying no to utilizing Harem
for children because he said he wouldn't
do that now again I I I I I think there
should be protections for children
obviously uh because children aren't
consenting adults and I think there's a
lot of predators out a lot of
Libertarians would call that the
question too absolutely exactly and then
and this is where I stand differently uh
this is this is where I disagree with
some of the larger ethos and the larger
philosophies